hi good evening everyone thanks for
invitation hernán the previous talks
were great so I'm at Tel Aviv University
I'm my training is mainly neuroscience a
bit of economics the fields of my study
are neuro economics and what we call
consumer neuroscience and I was asked
today to talk about mainly one branch of
our my studies in the lab which are
basically are using EEG data or neural
data in order to try to predict what you
will choose in the future what are your
preferences whether you like some
product or not now this is the more
applied part of my studies and I will
give you some examples of what we can do
with this the stool and what is the idea
behind it why do we even bother to use
the brain in order to predict choices so
think about that in marketing research
usually what we want to do is we want to
know whether a product will be a
successful which commercial to work with
and usually what happens is that the
standard way of research is either
giving people questionnaires or focus
groups and things like that which are
known to have many many biases that is
the main main problem and this is why a
lot of marketing campaigns aren't
unsuccessful people invest a lot of
money in it but they're unsuccessful and
the idea is that because it is one of
the reasons not just because the product
is not good but could be that the
product is very good but the campaign
was not good enough because the
measurements that were used are full of
biases for example when I get people to
answer questionnaires in many cases they
will for example will not say what they
truly believe or they don't even know
exactly what they're going to choose in
the future and they make up some
questions there are many many biases
example
focus groups usually will be like a
dominant person who will say what they
think and the other people were just not
with their head yes okay but it's not
really what they think or they're
embarrassed to tell that they vote voted
for Trump or they like guns or stuff
like that but it actually they will not
be implemented in there and the real
choices so what we think is that we can
overcome some of these biases of course
not all of them and that we could use
different measurements that we could
overcome these biases but also get a
some measurement of unconscious
information that questionnaires or focus
group or not even I cannot even induce
in the subjects where and the tool to do
that is to use neural and physiological
data our gonna present you data today
just with neural data but physiological
data could be either heartrate eye
movements skin conductance etc anything
that I could measure from the body that
could help me it to again gain
additional measurement to the standard
way that marketing is doing their
research now importantly the good the
goal is not to replace standard measures
if we could harness with all we just
showed you with a beautiful model that
will be the baseline okay we'll use
everything that we can have from
questionnaires and behavioral data but
the idea is to add an additional layer
that hopefully will gain a better
prediction then the standard way of the
people are doing research in marketing
research in most cases okay so the idea
is to better predict preferences and
campaigns etc now I will show you just a
brief short example this is it was a and
some TV program but it's just an example
of how marketing research in many cases
are done this is you'll see a woman
looking and with two boxes of milk and
she's asked like two questions which
look simple enough but I think that they
like her answer is like weird she she
doesn't
know what actually to say so it's a very
short one but it will emphasize what's
the main problem as I see it in
marketing research so I don't think it's
these weird questions I don't know what
it means
what is party or dislike everybody has
its own definition for that it's very
very very noisy so in the end this is
like standard marketing research and the
idea is maybe we can add some
information above and beyond those
standard measures ok so I'm summarizing
hundreds of studies some came from my
lab some came from other labs in the in
in the world we came to a conclusion
that there are several brain areas that
if we look at their activity it could
tell us something about the value that
people put on options it doesn't matter
which which what's what are the names of
these areas but this is the front of the
brain this is the back this is where
it's connected to to your spinal cord
but these two main regions are active in
any choice situation that was ever
measured inside a brain scan that means
that it doesn't matter if it you made
choices for money or for food or drinks
or finding sexual partners or investing
in stocks or negotiations anything that
was ever tested these brain areas coded
your valuation that means if you
preferred an option better the brain
activity in these areas was higher and
it that means it's these areas what are
called the common currency network
they're not the only areas but they're
the main areas that they're coding how
much you want something so that's basic
science it's interesting we wrote papers
the question is what can we do with that
the idea is that we we can maybe measure
values in the brain directly without
ask you asking you anything and we can
act and we can look for each of the
subjects at their brain activity and
rank the Preferences of their choices
goods or commercials whatever whatever
we give them just by looking at their
brain activity and maybe by using that
we can make better predictions and even
predict subjects future choices based on
their brain data that we measure right
now just to give you a concrete example
this is time this is let's consider this
is my brain and my brain activity and if
I look at this glass of water I'll have
some brain activity as a response to
that glass of water and for orange juice
but I like it a bit better so the brain
activity will be higher for Coke it'll
be higher for a glass of wine it's not
bad and I like very much beer so this is
how my brain activity will look like
that means I can just look at these
brain activation and try to predict
based on them the rank ordering of my
preference here without asking me
anything just by looking at specific
brain regions in this in a specific
brain the signal in the specific brain
regions now this result already been
done or just going to show you some
examples one of the first papers did did
this inside in the scanner at NYU and
they gave subjects to sit inside the
fMRI scanner by the way if you don't
know if MRI scanner is a standard MRI
scanner you have in the hospital that I
don't know if somebody already was
scanned by an MRI it's the same thing
it's a huge magnet
the only difference to make it fMRI it
means that I can measure your blood in
in the brain areas and we assume that a
brain area that is more activated will
attract more attract more blood that
means I assume that that brain area is
activated so they sat there inside the
fMRI scanner and they saw all kinds of
sorry all kind of goods could be his
this was way back in 2011
and they just sat there and they were
asked to think how much you value
something just and look and read and
they looked at the brain activity later
on half a half an hour later outside the
scanner without brain data at all they
had choose between all the possible
pairs what do you prefer this or that
whatever they had 20 different Goods so
for each of the individual subjects they
had a rank ordered preferences of all
their possibilities and then later on
they could decode look at the brain data
from the valuation areas and they were
able to predict what the individual
subjects would choose 30 minutes later
just based on the brain data from the
previous from the first phase that was
the first real experiment actually use
brain data in order to predict choices
actually future choices now this was
done later on with other stuff like
predicting whether I like or not cars
this was done also to predict the
success of songs the real success of
song in the world by just scanning 40
subjects giving them to to listen to
short clips from the from the songs
measure their brain activity and then by
using this focus bracing it what we call
neuro focus group in order to predict
their the success of the real songs in
the in the population this is already
also done for anti campaign anti-smoking
etc etc and also for crowdfunding people
saw in the scanner some information
about a possible project measured their
brain activity and then it was they were
able to predict which of the project
will eventually be funded which was not
and these are all interesting examples
of how we can use fMRI in order to
predict all kinds of valuation processes
and future success of things that
marketing marketers and business people
care about now there is a small problem
with all these studies for application
who knows how much anymore MRI
scanner costs about three to four
million dollars depends on the on the
machine you have to build a big room
with concrete walls for about 40 50
centimeters thick it's a big big
operation it costs each year also to
cool it you have special people so it's
not really really applicable for every
maybe play to combine different rife
they want but smaller businesses maybe
not so what we thought is say okay let's
try to use this same idea but to use a
simpler system in order to predict
marketing success or subjects future
choices so luckily there is a system
there is a machine it's already been
around for a hundred years in standard
research in academia and it's called eg
so the short is for electroencephalogram
it's a machine that writes electrical
brain signals and it looks like this
these are many many electrodes that are
stuck to your scalp and it just measures
the average brain activity from many
many many neurons now this is a fancy
system that costs the most expensive one
would cost around fifty thousand dollars
which is not a big deal but nowadays
there are actually what I call toys
which have one electrode two electrodes
maybe four to eight which are very very
cheap they're mobile you can use them
anywhere you want people use them in the
supermarket in cars in planes whatever
you want you can put a toy eg and
measure some brain activities so it is a
lot more applicable than then using fMRI
so the game the goal was to use this old
machine in order to predict actual
marketing success and and subjects
choices so we what we did is we said
let's do the simple experiment but now
instead of fMRI let's use EEG and this
is exactly what we did we gave subject
to look at products like product like
these all kinds of standard products
and we ask them just think how much
something is worth to you without doing
anything no behavior nothing at all and
then on the following phase without EEG
they had to choose binary choices what
do you prefer this or that you rank
order them and then by looking and
decoding the eg data we were able to
separate between the preferred option
and to the non preferred option which
the the choices were around 20 minutes
after this first stage now I don't know
if you asked yourself or not but how
good can we predict not just the EEG all
the fMRI experiments before us how good
can we predict well remember that when
we want to predict binary choices chance
is 50% I don't need anything just flip a
coin I'm 50% so we looked at all the
studies and the accuracy is ranging
between 60 to 80% 80% is pretty good if
you tell a marketer that you can predict
whether a commercial a or commercial B
will be better worth a lot of money 60%
is is not bad but not great so we want
to understand why sometimes it's 80% and
sometimes it's 60% so what we did to our
data
look at this x-axis it's actually
looking at the neural what we call the
neural distance look at think about the
activity between of two products and how
different they are in their preferences
number nine is when two products are
very very different in the preferences
for a given subject while product like
Norrell distance one is that the
products are very close so if you notice
when the products and the preferences
are very close the neural data is very
similar and we cannot predict anything
we're a chance level and only predict
very well when the distance is very very
far which makes sense but but that's
also a caveat in all these methods we
have to take this into consideration we
cannot read your mind it's very hard to
predict when the things are very very
close to each other and this is exact
what marketers one they want to know
whether I need to go with the brand or
the package with a slight different read
between the packages very very slight
differences nowadays I want to blow a
bubble here the neuroscience methods
that we have cannot differentiate when
the art of them when the options are
very very close to each other I don't
know what you read in the books but
that's just false it's very hard we need
to have them very very separate in order
to do something meaningful okay and then
later on other studies came and we're
able to show that we can predict Super
Bowl commercials and success in movie
trailers based on other people watched
movie trailers and then they looked in
real real life sales and also there was
a study that measured eg inside the
cinema while people watched movies and
they were able to predict their success
in general but what we I did not show
you yet is something that is very very
important is whether all these fancy
stuff whether they can do better then or
not better but whether they can add some
information to the standard measures if
it can just give people something you
don't questionnaire what do you prefer
commercial a or B I'm done I don't need
anything or if I can just use behavioral
measures to use prediction I don't need
the fancy brain it's nice to write
papers about it
it has big nice pictures but it's not
useful so the challenge is whether we
can use something with the brain to over
and to show prediction over and above
standard measures so this is what this
study is about it's was done by my
wonderful PhD student and I came and
then we did a very simple experiment
where we gave people a series of if you
remember the seed rockets of him so they
saw this short movie clips by psyllium
and then some commercials and then Salim
commercials
a half an hour we wanted to show them
like a real TV you know a half an hour
in front of the TV and during this phase
we measured their eg there were six
different commercials repeated several
times doesn't matter the details what's
important is that after the EEG session
we also gave them a standard marketing
questionnaire that is done in the
industry if fancy marketing company
wants to evaluate these commercials they
will give people this questionnaire how
much did you like it where they're gonna
buy it remember it
bla bla bla all kinds of questionnaires
what this gives us it gives us a
baseline of how good you know the
standard marketing questionnaire is it
doing and then at final stage each of
the products that they saw in this
commercial
they made binary choices so for each of
the subject we can rank order all their
preferences so that was number two so we
have the EEG data we have their baseline
questionnaire and we have their
preferences based on their binary
choices what the next thing what we did
is we took data from YouTube actually
because these were commercials that were
already out there and we got some
metrics of the YouTube success how much
how many views shares likes blah blah
etc that gave for each of the of the
commercials how much they were
successful in in the real market in the
population so what we wanted to do is
wanted to use this the eg in order to
predict their choices but Auction also
to predict marketing our YouTube success
and importantly what we had to show in
order to make this all viable is that we
can do better than what the
questionnaires are doing so I'm not
gonna go over all the results but to
make a long story short the
questionnaires we're doing not bad the
prep the prediction was pretty good what
we were able to show using various
machine learning methods which I don't I
don't have time to get into the details
it doesn't matter these are four
different measurements that by adding
the eg and four
the EEG features we were able to print
to increase the prediction rate compared
to - the questionnaires this means that
there are there is some information in
the neural data that is not in the
questionnaires so we were very happy in
that and last here in this study we were
also able to show is that we were able
to predict the real marketing success as
measured by YouTube based on the same
features of the EEG data which were
which means that it's not just we can
use these features not just to predict
the the in group choices of these guys
who we measured their brain but if the
the group is representative to the
population we can actually say something
about the prediction of the population
now the last thing is this is a very
brand-new project we said okay let's use
instead of using machine learning to
decode the information let's use some
deep learning models this is fancy now
so that's why not let's do that I'm
joking but the the main idea to use deep
learning not just because it's
successful it's because all the the
previous models that we use even in
machine learning we have to choose the
features we have to input like what all
we said we have to give the model the
the features now in eg they're endless
features part and responsible features
when you do pre-processing of eg data
even before you start the analysis some
people are calculated you have more than
10,000 possibilities that the subjects
re that the experiment and need to
choose in order to say ok I'm going with
these features and not these I'm
cleaning the data like this and not so
this gives you know it's an endless
problem and it could cause a lot of
biases and in the deep learning we can
just we throw in the raw data we're not
putting any features we're letting the
system do its thing and and let it
predict now I'm not going to go into the
details but it was a simple experiment
subject saw a product and three
later it had to to state their
willingness to pay how much do you want
to buy this product $2 $7 $15 whatever
and we want to use the EEG data from
here to predict this point there were
various different Goods different Goods
types about 80 different products so I'm
not going to go into the network but
this is one just one piece of the
convolutional neural network which this
is instead of doing the pre-processing
and filtering by hand you want the
system to decode all the different
features frequencies clean the data all
that by using these convolutional
networks what you saw here is one one
here you have we had many of these we
had a part which is also important to
try to decode or to take into account
because this is a time series to take
into account dependencies between the
points and to take into account
dependencies between trials think about
in a game that and each time you play
the game there is um dependencies this
also takes that into account and this is
preliminary data but we have some pretty
nice predictions using the deep learning
we're very excited what's nice about
this is you can later on go back and try
to decode these features at the deep
learning shows and you're not familiar
with eg data but this is not eg data
that we did the pre-processing these are
outputs of the deep learning network
they can actually now go we can go back
and get insights of what are the real
features that were beneficial it could
help us in order to predict so that's it
I just want to summarize I think there
is information in neural data in order
to predict various things but it's not
to replace standard and behavioral
models and data science and all that
it's just we think we can add an
additional prediction success or
prediction rate above and beyond
whatever other people
doing so that's it thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]